would you rather be a like if somebody
said would you rather be a rock star or
an actor I'd say rock star I'd rather be
a rock star if I had you know and I have
a band and we play and we do we don't
try to be rock stars we're just I write
all the music and uh Rob and I just work
well together and we love to play
Virtual live and we played some out and
we have two albums and we just enjoy it
and love it and there's a passion and do
you still have that passion for music I
know now you're a mom you're a mom and
you've got all this stuff going on do
you still like because you you've had
albums you've had success I mean a lot
of success but do you want to continue
do you want to continue music do you
want to still kind of keep writing and
playing no I haven't written in a very
long time why um BEC I I I have a very
complicated relationship with like music
when it involves me I love music I am
staring at my record player in my
handful of records that are like that
I've kept away from my moving boxes and
I'm so excited to get that back going I
bought a piano just so I could hear the
sound of my children like slamming their
fingers into it I just love that noise
God you like that noise I love it oh I
love it because they're just they
because I always I spent so long like
one of the things I kept saying in this
last year which could bring me down a
whole other tangent so I will attempt
not to do that but that I I like last
year um my entire personality became
Golf and it kind of became like a joke
for a while um wow I love golf you're
playing golf well I was playing golf
it's it's a bigger Longer story um but I
accidentally became like a golfer and um
and but I was not but I'm not good at it
and but because nobody's get a golf I I
mean but I'm not great at it and so I
was trying to be but what I wanted to do
was be better at being like being good
at not being great at something like
that is what I've really wanted to be
better at and I and I remember being
like I want my kids to be able to just
play messy keys on a piano and not have
to be like no this sounds good and this
sounds bad because when you're creating
art like I I would just be paralyzed by
like a white piece of paper and if I
started something that I had decided
like wasn't the way it was supposed to
turn out I'd be like well then what's
the point and I just like I want to
create an an environment in which like
you know there is no like one sound of
and they'll find it like I wish I'd had
that to just be able to like play a
bunch of keys and and wonder like how
does this sound what is this and be
curious as opposed to um so constricted
I love what you just said and what I
interpret that
as is for
me it's always I'm playing softball
tonight I've got to be great I've got to
hit a home run I've got to be the star
I'm going to play anything we play
cornhole the other night I got to
freaking show everybody I'm a cornhole
master I'm going to write a great script
I'm you're putting so much pressure on
yourself and you're not enjoying things
that you're like I have to be perfect
and the reality is you can't be so if
you could just enjoy things that you're
not really great at but you enjoy doing
them and watching your kids just mess up
and learn that it's okay to just be
stupid and playful and happy and I think
that's because we put so much pressure
on ourselves
and the world we feel like the world
puts pressure that we have to like if we
put something out there oh it has to
sound great it has to be because we have
to compete we have to show that we're
just as good and what I gather is that
you're saying in a lot of ways you want
to just be able to not put as much
pressure on yourself and just enjoy
things